hello
my name is brooks gross my colleague and
co-organizer
dr carrie ashmont and i are program
officers at the national institute of
neurological disorders and stroke
we actively participate in the brain
initiative and each manage portfolios of
translational device grants that include
brain-funded projects
we are delighted to welcome you to this
brand initiative scientific symposium
titled advances in human neuroscience
this session will highlight recent
advances made towards understanding the
human nervous system
speakers will also present
considerations they encounter and there
were epic considerations they encounter
in their work
if you have any questions for the
speakers please type them in the q
a box during the presentations please
address your questions
to a specific speaker if possible we
will be curating your questions as they
come
in and we'll do our best to answer as
many questions as possible during the
live q a
session at the end of the symposium now
i would like to introduce our first
speaker
dr jen collinger a research biomedical
engineer at the va r d center of
excellence
and an assistant professor in the
department of physical medicine and
rehabilitation at the university of
pittsburgh
all right well thank you to brooks and
kerry for inviting me here to talk about
some of the work that we've been doing
at the university of pittsburgh
using a neuroscience-based approach to
try to restore grasp function
after spinal cord injury so now as many
of you
likely know after spinal cord injury
your level of function really depends on
the level of the injury itself
and we're interested in trying to
restore upper limb function to people
with tetraplegia or quadriplegia
who have an injury at the cervical
spinal cord and so this study that was
done in 2004
demonstrated quite clearly that people
with quadriplegia really prioritize
restoration of arm and hand function
over all other functional recovery
priorities
and so our research group is trying to
use brain computer interfaces or bcis
to tap into a brain activity that
remains intact after injury
to try to bridge that injured spinal
cord and restore movement
this slide here shows you know sort of
an overview of our approach
so we're using what we call a
bi-directional bci
where it's it's a circular loop that
we can record activity from the brain so
shown in blue there is the motor cortex
and there's two microelectrode arrays
that are implanted into motor cortex
in our study you can see an image of one
off to the top right of the slide
that actually lets us record from single
neurons or small groups of neurons in
the brain
we can record and look at the patterns
of activity and turn that into a control
signal for
a robotic arm and at the same time
we can record from sensors in that
robotic arm
and turn that into stimulation patterns
for electrode arrays that are implanted
into somatosensory cortex to try to
restore the sense of touch
and so we know a lot about how motor
cortex is involved in controlling
reaching movements
and grasping movements from you know
decades of work that have been done in
non-human primates
and so um you know we've been doing a
lot of work to try to restore reaching
and simple grasping activities
and now have the ability to provide the
sense of touch to somebody with spinal
cord injury
where we can actually generate
sensations that feel like they're coming
from the person's fingers
and we can grade the intensity of those
sensations
this video will give you an idea of the
typical level of performance that we're
able to achieve
using the bci to control this robotic
arm so the participant is in control of
the endpoint velocity of the robotic arm
moving it around in three-dimensional
space as well as three-dimensional
orientation of the wrist
and opening and closing all of the
fingers as a group and so here they're
using the vci to perform the action
research arm test it's a test of upper
limb function
where the goal of the task is to pick up
the object and place it on a raised
surface
and so you can see that the bci is
really enabling a fairly natural and
smooth control over the robotic arm
and with smartest sensory feedback this
performance only improves
so using population level recordings
from motor cortex
we can actually restore simultaneous and
continuous control over all of these
degrees of freedom
you know to restore fairly natural
looking reaching and grasping movement
so what we're interested in now now that
we have the ability to restore some
reaching movements as well as sensation
is trying to focus on control of the
hand
and so we know that the ability to
regulate your grasped force is critical
for many activities of daily living you
know something adventurous
like rock climbing or playing tennis um
but even very simple things like
holding on to your briefcase and making
sure you don't drop it or shaking hands
or
you know interacting with fragile
objects such as
cracking an egg and so we really want to
try to understand
as much as we can how motor cortex is
involved in controlling grasped force in
order to
take a biometic approach to restoring
this function for somebody with spinal
cord injury
and so today i'm going to talk about
work that was done by brian zaclava
a postdoc in my laboratory who really
wanted to understand how grass force was
controlled across a variety of contexts
so he you know within the context of our
study
had the participant tried to perform
these different actions so on the left
you see an image of a virtual
environment
where the task is to observe and attempt
to
control that that virtual hand to grasp
an
object and they were asked to grasp it
with either a soft or firm force
the next iteration of that task we call
the grasp and 1d
carry is that there's a cylinder that
appears in the workspace either on the
left or right side
the user is instructed to think about
grasping it with a soft or firm force
and then move it to the other target so
it's very simple you either move left or
right depending on where you start
on the right hand side you can see a
virtual environment where the task now
is to grasp
and 3d carry and so what that means is
that the targets could appear
at select locations within the
three-dimensional workspace and so there
was more uncertainty and complexity
as to the reaching movement that would
be required after the user
grasped that object and so again this
work was happening in the context of our
brain computer interface studies
so brian was looking at neural
recordings from motor cortex of a person
who had a chronic spinal cord injury at
the c5 c6
level you know and the reason he wanted
to look at this activity across a
variety of contexts was because
there'd been some non-human primate work
it really suggested that motor cortex
firing was context dependent
and specifically what i'm referring to
for the study referenced here at
raymond was that the firing rates were
modulated based on the range of forces
that the monkeys were asked to achieve
so two different force levels might have
a different firing rate
when performed in a two target task as
opposed to a three target task
so what brian did was we had the
recordings like i mentioned we can
compute the firing rate for all of the
channels across time
and then use dimensionality reduction to
try to look at the overall population
level activity
which is something that's commonly being
done in this field right now so here
we're just looking at the first three
principal components of the population
activity
when the participant was attempting
either a high force
shown in dark purple or a low force
grasp shown in light purple
and so you can see that they have you
know a fairly stereotyped pattern
that looks very similar except they're
different in magnitude
and so what brian did is um found two
different axes that described two
different types of responses that
contained information about force
and so if we look at the projection of
this activity onto these two different
axes
we see what we call a transient mode so
the projection along that transient axis
shows that there's a peak in activity
kind of early on in the trial right at
the time of force onset so that dash
line is showing the computer controlled
force that the user was attempting to
to generate and you can see that there's
a large response for the large force
target in dark red and a small response
for the low force target in the lighter
red
and if we look at the projection onto
the other axis which we call the tonic
axis
you can see that after that initial
force onset while the force is being
held
but there's again a modulated activity
based on the high force or low force
target shown in dark or light blue
and so we consistently see these
different modes of activity
in our population level recordings
now what does it look like across the
different tasks well this is the data
that i just showed you
i'm only going to show the high force
target data right now but again we're
looking at the
magnitude of the projection of the
neural activity
onto this transient and red and tonic
axis
if we look at this activity for the
grasp plus the one-dimensional carry
you know again during that initial
application of the grasp
movement at the beginning there you can
see that there's a transient
response in the population shown in red
that looks very similar to the grasp
only task
but during the carry phase you know we
do see that there's a tonic response but
it's a little bit lower in magnitude as
a
compared to the grasp only task
and then when we look at the
three-dimensional carry task again we
see
a transient response initially as the
grasp is applied
but during the carry phase throughout
the three-dimensional workspace
that tonic response is reduced in
magnitude
and we can quantify this by looking at
the ratio of the peak magnitude
in the tonic dimension as compared to
the transient dimension
what we found is that as the task
complexity increased so the
number of degrees of freedom that needed
to be controlled or the number of
targets that were available
this ratio decreased and so initially
during the grasp only case
the ratio was approximately one where
the tonic and transient components had a
similar magnitude
but that was decreased as the kinematic
complexity was increased
and so what this meant for designing a
new grass force decoder is that we seem
to have very stable and reliable
information
during that transient phase and no
matter what if you're applying a high
grasp force
the population response looked similar
during that transient phase
but that tonic grass force information
was unreliable because it was context
dependent
and so brian came up with the idea to
design a decoder that preferentially
weighted this transient force
information
and so he was using a standard kalman
filter to control
grasp force in our bci where the force
output is really a measure of
the incoming neural activity that is
transformed into force
as well as a measure of the the force of
the previous time step
and so the kalman filter gain really
regulates how much you weight
incoming information versus historical
information
and so brian did was insert another
module in here where we can actually
detect what is the probability that the
user is
in this transient state of actively
trying to train change their grasp force
and if that probability is high we know
that they want to
you know actively change and modulate
the amount of force that they're
applying so we should probably pay more
attention to the incoming neural
information
and less so to the historical
information you know but conversely if
they're not in a transient state if
they're in that tonic state
we know that they probably want to just
keep doing what they're doing and
maintain that same grasp force
so in order to implement this this is
just one example of a task
where the user was asked to pick up an
object and move it back and forth across
the table as many times as they could
without dropping it
using a standard kalman filter approach
you can see that they were able to
generate
different forces for a high and low
force target there in dark and light
green
but they were dropping the object pretty
consistently after four or five seconds
with the transient weighted decoder they
could maintain that performance for much
longer regularly on the order of 30
seconds
so this is something that we're
continuing to develop and quantify
for a variety of tasks you know but i
think what
brian has shown so far is that the
cortical control of grasp
has both these transient tonic
components and
the tonic grass force information is
really context dependent and depends on
the complexity of the task
so we're trying to use these
biologically inspired decoding
approaches to improve
performance and here we've shown that it
can enable prolonged grasping and
transport
there's a lot of work to do still to
evaluate how this actually
translates to functional performance on
tasks just providing some other sensory
feedback
improve or change the ability to to
regulate grasp force
and we want to increase the kinematic
complexity of the hand so really moving
towards dexterous movements
so one last um closing thought i was
asked to talk about implications for
small end studies so with a low number
of participants
you know i think there are a lot of
opportunities we get to work with
participants for
many years who come in multiple times
per week and they really provide unique
insights into the studies it also allows
us to really maximize the benefit and
risk
ratio with each participant because we
can sort of make big leaps in device
development or science between
participants
you know but of course there are
challenges related to generalizability
statistical power and trying to
translate this technology for a small
market and so i'd be happy to
talk about this during during the q a
session
but i'd like to thank all of the
collaborators who've really contributed
to this project as well as the
funding from nih and darpa that has
allowed us to do this work
of course i have to thank our study
participants without whom this wouldn't
be possible
so thank you for your attention and i'd
like to uh now just introduce our next
speaker
kareem zaghool
so thank you for inviting us to present
our work my name is kareem zaglul and
i'm an investigator in the intramural
program here at the national institutes
of health and our lab is primarily
focused on understanding the neural
mechanisms that underlie human episodic
memory formation
and so what i wanted to say was describe
a recent study that we just completed
examining how sequences of spiking
activity are
replayed in the cortex when individuals
retrieve memories
now the motivation for this work and one
of the key pieces of evidence that has
shaped how we think about memory emerges
from the literature on spatial
navigation and rodents
this is a schematic summary of that
literature and what we can see
are the presence of what are known as
place cells these are individual neurons
that respond to the locations that a
rodent is in when they are traversing a
spatial environment
such that when a rodent is moving along
the track what you'll see is a sequence
of firing of those place cells
now remarkably what happens when the
mouse is asleep and at rest and
perhaps consolidating their memory or at
rest and may be thinking about the track
is that we see a replay of these
sequences
uh and for many years it has been
inferred that these replay of spiking
activity must have something to do with
memory
yeah we haven't had such direct evidence
that spike replay plays an important
role in human memory retrieval
now we also know is that these replay
events also happen in the context of
this other physiological signal
known as a ripple which is a fast
oscillation in the field potential
recordings from the medial temporal
lobes in the rodent
brain so i'm going to show you today is
a story that uh
is comprised of four parts first i'm
going to show you that we can record
ripples in the human cortex and the
reflect burst of spiking activity
i'm going to show you that these spikes
are ordered in a specific temporal order
or sequence
i'm going to show you that when you
retrieve memories you actually replay
these
spike sequences and the extent to which
we see such replay is actually enhanced
when we see ripples
in the medial temporal lobe the
behavioral paradigm that we use for this
task is
what's known as a verbal paired
associates memory task so in this task
we present our subjects with pairs of
words we instruct them to form these
novel associations
they solve some simple math problems as
a way of distraction and then
subsequently during testing we cue them
with one word from each pair
and their job is to remember what the
associated word is and this paradigm
gives us an important advantage because
it gives us direct control over what
memories they're trying to encode and
importantly what memory they're trying
to retrieve
and when they're trying to retrieve it
and so we can see what cycling activity
looks like during encoding and then
during retrieval
so if we take a look at our recordings
that we capture from our clinical
context we can identify these ripples
uh this is our three electrodes the
middle temporal gyrus and the cortex
and electrode and medial temporal lobe
we've previously shown that the presence
of these ripples are linked with memory
formation
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to ask what happens to underlying
spiking activity
and to do this we actually implant these
microelectrode arrays
in our in our human participants who are
getting
clinical implants for seizure monitoring
this gives us an opportunity to record
activity both at this larger spatial
scale as well as at the smaller spatial
scale
we primarily place these arrays in the
anterior temporal lobe because this is a
region that we anticipate we're going to
resect a subsequent surgery
and a region that we think is involved
in their seizure activity and what we
find is that every time we see a ripple
event we see
a clear burst of spiking activity from
multiple neurons that are required by
this microelectrode array
and even within the array itself if we
look at the individual channels we can
see that each channel actually exhibits
this small micro ripple and the extent
which we see a ripple actually
correlates with
uh the spiking activity on that channel
okay so we've now seen that the ripples
are associated with these bursts of
spiking activity so now let's see what
happens within these bursts so what i'm
showing you here
is a single example of a burst of
spiking activity uh with the firing rate
of each individual neuron shot on the
right
and what we can do is we can actually
reorder these neurons so we know which
one fires first and we color that blue
and which one fires
last within that burst and so now if we
look at a single trial in our experiment
what we see is that every trial
involves multiple bursts of spiking
activity
and what we find is that the order of
spiking within the
first burst is actually preserved across
all the subsequent bursts so the neuron
that fired first
in that first burst tenth of fire later
in the susquehanna burst the neurons of
fire later the yellow neurons in that
first burst tend to fire
later subsequent bursts so now we can
look at what the sequence looks like
in one trial so in this trial the
subject is studying the word pair steam
and seal we can see that the blue
neurons fire earlier and the yellow
neurons fire later
and now we can ask what the same neurons
are doing in a second different trial
and what we find
is that when we observe a burst event in
that second trial
the neurons have actually changed their
order so the early neurons who fired
first
in the first trial tend to fire later in
the second trial then the runs will fire
later in that first trial tend to fire
earlier in that second trial
and now we can actually quantify the
extent to which sequences are similar to
one another using a metric known as a
matching index we can use any metric and
it gives the same result
and so what we're going to ask is how
similar the sequences are for
all the births within a given trial
compared to the first across different
trials
and what we find is that for the correct
encoding trials there's significantly
more similarity
within a trial than across different
trials and this is not true for the
incorrect trials so this suggests that
when you're correctly encoding an item
into memory
it actually involves a very specific
sequences of spiking activity
and so now we want to know what happens
during memory retrieval and so what i'm
showing you here is an example
of a trial during encoding where they
are studying the word pair crow and jeep
we can see a sequence of spiking
activity
as we said earlier if we look across the
entire trial we see multiple bursts of
activity that all have the same sequence
and now during retrieval we give them
the word jeep and they say the word crow
and what we find
is that there are also bursts of
activity that emerge during retrieval
and they have actually a very similar
pattern of spiking sequence
to the sequences that were present
during encoding and in fact retrieval
also involves multiple bursts of
fighting activity so
here the word jeep comes on the screen
at the stash line
they vocalize the word crow at zero and
what you can see is that there are
multiple bursts of activity
all of them having very similar
sequences and as we get closer and
closer to vocalization
the sequences become more and more
similar to the sequences that were
present during encoding
so this is true across all of our
subjects and across all of our correct
trials what we found
was that there was greater sequence
similarity uh during retrieval until the
time people vocalize their response
compared to the incorrect trials
the bar graph below just captures the
difference between the correct and
incorrect sequence similarity
during this time period of retrieval
what we also find
is that if we perform a simple shuffling
analysis that the sequences are specific
to the individual trials that are being
retrieved
if we shuffle all the trials we find
that there isn't uh such sequence
similarity
what we also find is that during this
process of special retrieval we actually
get
overall decreases in population spiking
rates and so together what all these
data suggests
is that successful memory retrieval
involves sparse yet very temporally
precise
sequences of neural uh activity that are
replayed
finally we want to know how is this
related to the ripples and
particularly the ripples that we know
are coupled between the cortex and the
mtl these sequences are recorded in the
cortex but in the mtl we can actually
capture
individual ripples we don't have access
to the spiking activity in the mtl but
our hypothesis is that
if we observe the sequence of spiking
activity in the context of this cortical
ripple
and this cortical ripple happens at the
same time as this mtl ripple
then perhaps those might be the times
when these sequences are more temporally
ordered
what i'm showing you here is another
example trial we have multiple bursts of
activity
again from the cortical electrode mtg we
see these multiple ripples
corresponding with each of these bursts
uh but we also have a recording
electrode in the medial temporal lobe
and we can see that there's a ripple
that appears in the mtl that happens at
the same time
as one of the ripples in the mtg and it
turns out that
this sequence here that's happening
during this couple event is actually
more similar to the sequences that were
present during encoding
and in fact we just find this is true
across our population
that if we look at the sequences that
are present during the coupled ripples
they tend to be more similar to the
encoding sequences than
those sequences of presence during the
uncoupled ripples so together what these
data tell us then
is that this ability to replay your
sequences of spiking activity is in some
way associated with these ripples that
are coupled between these structures
so in conclusion what our work has shown
then is that we
have identified ripples in the human
cortex and they actually reflect
underlying burst spiking activity these
spikes are ordered in a very specific
temporal sequence
memory retrieval replays this sequence
and this replay is enhanced
when we observe couple rip couple
ripples in the medial temporal lobe
and so finally uh i think uh i want to
conclude
by finishing up this presentation by
discussing some of the ethical issues
that we think are important to consider
whenever engaging this type of research
these are issues that we take quite
seriously and we spend considerable time
discussing these with our colleagues
both within and outside of nih but also
with our bioethicists
there have been of course several good
discussions about this but i'm going to
summarize three major points here
so first there's a question of placing
both standard clinical electrodes as
well as the special microelectrodes here
for research i think the fundamental
ethical issue comes down to balancing
the additional risks associated with any
electrodes
versus the potential gains and
fundamental knowledge both knowledge
regarding
epilepsy as a disease but also knowledge
regarding human brain function
obviously any knowledge isn't going to
be of benefit to the individual
participant but will hopefully be a
benefit to future patients
in our approach we're very careful that
how we decide to place the electrodes we
only place our standard clinical
electrodes
in brain regions that we where there's a
clear indication to monitor
the additional microelectro arrays like
the ones used in this study involve a
separate consideration however
in our view we believe that the risks of
placing these arrays are similar to the
risks of placing an additional clinical
electrode
uh but they're not zero which means that
as best as possible we try to place
these electrodes
in areas of the brain that we anticipate
we're going to eventually resect
in our hands so far what we've seen is
that eighty percent of the time when
subjects go on to receive a reception we
have indeed resected the region where
these rays were placed
and so there's no long-term consequences
however there is a subset of patients in
whom we have not pointed a reception
and so we're very careful about
following these patients and so far
we've not seen any changes in feature
frequency or any other adverse events
um the remaining two issues involve
patient consent and patient autonomy for
patient consent i think a good approach
is to try to separate as much as
possible between consenting the patient
to the research procedure
from those contenting the patient to the
clinical procedure and we try to do that
we don't want to provide
the patients with any sense that there's
an obligation to participate or any
conflicts of interest
we have a dedicated team of research
nurses that can sense our participants
to their research procedures
and this team is separate both from our
clinical team who are discussing surgery
but they're also separate from the
actual research
team that conducts the study and
collects and analyzes the data
and then this finally leads to the
patient question of patient autonomy
there is a patient i'll tell you of
course at the consent stage where it
needs to make clear that they can choose
to participate or not participate with
any consequences on their clinical care
but it's also true even during testing
so we test these patients on a daily
basis
however we make it very clear to the
patients that even during the testing
sessions they have the right to refuse
to participate
and that should have no consequences for
their clinical care and we emphasize
this to the entire clinical staff
including the nurses that are taking
care of the patient
to make sure the patient is aware that
the two are completely decoupled
so these are the main issues that we
consider here and i think uh that we
think about in terms of these patients
in this type of work but i'm happy to
discuss this further if anyone's
interested
and then finally i want to conclude by
thanking all of the current and foreign
members of our lab and in particular i
want to thank alex vaz who is an
outstanding phd student in our lab
who is largely responsible for the work
that i presented today
thank you very much and now i want to
introduce our next speaker who is helen
mayberg
thanks
thank you kareem it's a pleasure to be
with all of you and to present our
latest work
from our uh 3 grant funded by the brain
initiative
i'll be speaking about our latest
findings
in our examination of mechanisms of deep
brain stimulation for
treatment resistant depression um
disclosures is that the basis of this
work is
the focus of intellectual property
that's been issued to abbott labs
i want to start by framing the problem
because treatment resistant depression
isn't just a regular depression
we're talking in this presentation
about strategies to treat patients
without options
and if one's ever listened to
the symptoms of a patient
with this condition one is struck
by the presence of intolerable pain
of the mental type and the fact that one
can't seem to find
the mental strategy to do much about it
and if one reaches a point of treatment
resistance
it means that there are no
treatment strategies that have been
successful and that's the context in
which this
um experimental study lives
this work has been going on for many
years um
in several of my previous labs and it
started with an idea
about the relationship of what mediates
negative mood in the brain and how
negative
mood actually hijacks in tension
and movement and through a series of
studies starting
back on 15 years ago
we implanted in a putative brain
location
area 25 the subcolossal cingulate
with a hypothesis that this region
was stuck on and that it mediated
negative effect
and that if one blocked activity there
you could release
abnormally connected cortical regions
and evoke clinical improvement
and through a series of multiple
iterative small experiments
we found that we could both shift
acutely negative mood and affect a
clinical response
that evolved not immediately but over
time
and now at emory we have nearly a 200
patient year experience
in a small but significant
cohort of patients and have found that
we can actually
remediate this chronic condition
and have found that people can live
without relapse for a period of
many many years so what motivated us
in these new studies was an observation
that evolved
as our
method for implantation improved
and as we optimize the implantation
procedure
using tractography we started to notice
that actually one could reset the
behavior
very rapidly in the operating room
that if one left the stimulator off
for a month after surgery you actually
had a significant carryover
in the month after surgery that was only
associated when you actually gave
stimulation in the operating room
it wasn't induced if you did the
operation
sleep and it wasn't seen
without active stimulation in the
operating room
the other thing that we noticed was that
after a couple of months on chronic stem
that almost all patients went through a
period of emotional instability
for lack of a better word and that
with minor adjustments or even no
adjustments of the stimulation in some
cases
it corrected the other thing that became
obvious
and important to pursue was that
different patients
even if at the end of six months were
better had
variable courses so
to tune a dvs device we basically have
used the same settings for all
phases of this recovery trajectory
but we see this variable rate of
improvement across individuals and so
what we really need
are target engagement biomarkers that
can basically help us to know
who to implant how to make adjustments
to have longitudinal readouts of both
the brain
and the behavior and to have that to
develop rules for how to adjust the
device
and even think about closed loop
technologies
the work at atlanta involved a large
team and they
are one of our three sites
and we've implemented in the uh3 the use
of
prototype dbs devices that not only
allow stimulation but also sensing
we've combined measurements of local
field potentials
off the area of stimulation in the
subcolossal cingulate
with concurrent but intermittent high
density eeg
to both track the biological signal
of target engagement in meaning
when we know when we're in the right
place
as a prediction as well as how to track
over time the recovery curve in patients
we combine the brain recordings
with the obvious measures of self-report
and the gold standard depression
severity ratings
but have also started to pilot on
measurements
on quantitative measurements of movement
of autonomic function and of even
emotional facial expression voice
and content but i want to just present
now briefly
is basically um a component
of what we have done and have ongoing in
this study
we've now completed phase one which is
ten patients implanted
with the pc sas system for ongoing
recording of local field potentials in
area 25
over six months we have ongoing
experiments that will be presented in
the team poster
on target engagement biomarkers both
with
tractography and with evoked responses
off the cortical surface
um i want to present briefly what we're
seeing
however in our depression state markers
where
we have early clues now that there is
indeed a reset
that we can detect in the operating room
that sets the stage for chronic changes
that evolve over six months
um this is the first presentation
of our clinical outcome
in this new cohort of 10 treatment
resistant patients
they're again a mix of men and women
middle age onset in early adulthood
of the melancholic type with recurrent
major depression
and average duration of ect resistant
depression of about five years
we used our method for tractography
guided
individual target localization
in real time in the operating room we
confirmed
in all subjects that we matched a
published template that we derived from
our earlier cohorts
and in this group as you can see from
the
timeline of the depression recovery
curve is that nine of the ten patients
were responders of six months
with six in remission so having this
kind of outcome
really put us in a good position to
track the local fuel potential
changes over time an important first
observation was that in this study we
have been implanting
both devices in the brain with the
patient awake
and then giving active stimulation
bilaterally really initiating
therapeutic stimulation in the operating
room
for the purposes of tracking what
exactly is
that behavioral reset we have
behavioral self-reports when one is in
the
optimized location versus the
non-optimized location
on either side of the brain but one gets
an added effect
with super threshold stimulation
bilaterally
at the optimal target and what we've
shown through
a machine learning approach to
bands eliminated power at the local
field potential
measured from area 25 is that there's a
multi-band
change the machine learning
algorithm has extracted that what drives
the change between the baseline and the
end
of bilateral stimulation is
a beta decrease
and an alpha increase on the right so
there's a bilateral beta
and alpha increase on the right it's
seen in everyone
and it predicts
what the carryover the behavioral effect
is over the ensuing
week with a strong correlation with the
decrease in that beta signal
we have support that this may in fact be
a reset
because as patients wait to start
chronic stimulation
for a month after insertion and testing
in the operating room
we see a regression a return of their
hamilton depression rating scale score
at different rates in different patients
and what we've done
by now measuring off the pc plus s
device directly is that one can detect
a return in the beta signal after about
a week
and again high data actually is the
driver
of this re-emergence of symptoms
shankar has gone on to actually then
characterize off the pc plus s
what is the driver and is beta related
to the change in behavior
over time that's accompanying chronic
stimulation
and what we see is if one compares the
relative power change
in the first month of stimulation
compared to the last month of
stimulation
we actually see early that there's a
decrease
very much like the operating room but to
our surprise
as one gets to the actual recovery
at measured at six months it's a net
beta increase and this was quite
confusing because the machine learning
algorithm could not
actually find a relationship between the
magnitude of the behavior
and the power but what we actually
came to discover was that the beta
was actually switching its power
and direction of its activity over time
with chronic stem so our next real focus
is to understand what drives the beta
switch and that will be the focus of our
next
studies we've also tried in parallel
to really look at why doesn't
this beta or any of our lsb changes
track with the rating itself and what we
found
by exploring through video analysis what
goes on in the voice
in facial expression that actually this
switch period
in the lfp is accompanied by a
prediction
and a stability in the face and the
voice that we've discerned through an
analysis
of behavior and the absence
of patient self-report
we're now geared up to start phase two
using the next generation rc plus s
platform and we'll be continuing these
kinds of studies to actually have higher
fidelity data to actually track
at home not only the depression
severity states but also patient
self-support
and ongoing fluctuations in their
emotional state
and in their movement with higher
fidelity recordings
and i just want to end um with the
notion that there are some pragmatic
considerations
as we have these patients doing
incredibly well
um having participated in these very
demanding experiments
but where we're using prototype devices
that have no commercial support
and i think this is an important thing
for us to consider
that when we actually have success in
these elaborate experiments trying to
understand the biology of these
disorders
we now have devices that have no
commercial support
that are expected to be active for more
than 10 years
and we need a plan that we hadn't
thought of in terms of
what is the patient to do that they're
now tied to a prototype
what is the burden for the pis for the
patients for the families for industry
for nih
and to even consider can an ill patient
in these states really appreciate the
future consequences of decisions made at
the time of
consent and i think that we need as a
community
to be thinking about strategies of how
we might even
replace these prototype devices with
commercial devices
after these studies are done the other
thing i want to end in is that
it also appears that despite these
readouts dds
is necessary but clearly not sufficient
in people
who have this degree of severe
psychiatric illness and the patients
themselves come to realize over time
that actually they need rehabilitation
and i think we have to start thinking
about
how biological study design incorporates
not just the engineering
needs but actually the psychotherapeutic
needs
and with that i'd like to introduce our
next speaker
chris abbott
i am chris abbott from the university of
new mexico and i'll be summarizing our
results from our brain investigation
project
the title of this presentation is neural
correlates with ect dosing
and depression ect is the most effective
treatment for severe
treatment-resistant depressive episodes
with effect sizes around 0.8 relative to
pharmacotherapy
although transient ect mediated
cognitive impairment can impact
all cognitive domains and delay the
recovery from severe depressive episodes
importantly ect mediated cognitive
impairment perpetuates the stigma with
this procedure
despite abundant ect neuroimaging
investigations to the contrary
ect opponents cite this side effect as
evidence of brain damage
the fear of cognitive impairment can be
dissuasive for someone that otherwise
meets the indication for this procedure
ecc clinicians individualize the dose
with seizure titration
a method of limits determination of the
minimum dose necessary to achieve
seizure initiation the other aspect to
minimize the cognitive risk is the
choice of electrode placement
of the three commonly used electrode
placements this investigation will focus
on right in the lateral electro
placement
which has the least risk of
neurocognitive impairment
regarding the stimulus train the method
of limits determination necessary to
initiate seizure activity
is a combination of increasing the pulse
strain duration initially
followed by a subsequent increase in
frequency to increase the number of
pulses
the amplitude is held constant at either
eight or nine hundred milliamps
there is no clinical or scientific
rationale for this fixed amplitude
related to ect
the electric field modeling has
demonstrated that the eight or nine
hundred million at fixed amplitudes
are six times greater than the amplitude
sufficient for neuronal activation
other neuromodulation treatments such as
deep brain stimulation
and transdirect current stimulation
readily recognize the importance and
manipulate amplitude to achieve desired
outcomes
relevant to this investigation amplitude
also determines the electric field
strength
our steady design randomized subjects to
6
7 and 800 milliamp amplitudes with right
bilateral electron placement
based on our preliminary data 500
milliamp was ineffective and therefore
not utilized in this design
although it is possible to use during
with a standard ect
device the 800 milliamp arm was the
active comparator
we assessed depression severity
cognitive performance in
imaging pre-mid-ect which was defined
after the sixth ect
treatment and post-ect which was
variable
if subjects failed to respond during
their midpoint assessment which was
defined as a 25
reduction in depression severity
subjects would then receive bite and
coral electro placement for the
remainder of their ect series
the rationale for the mid-series switch
to bytes and portal was to ensure that
the protocol would not compromise
subjects potential to respond to the ect
series
our subject flow is summarized here
notable findings include that the
attrition rate was low
and we had equivalent attrition among
three arms
and the equivalent switch rate to bi2
coral electrode placement
the analyses that we'll present include
everybody who completed at a minimum of
the second visit
the three amplitude arms had equivalent
age sex and clinical characteristics
this investigation did focus on an older
depressed patient population
characterized with unipolar depression
at an age range between
50 and 80 years of age the final charge
and average seizure duration were also
similar to the treatment arms
our primary outcome measure included the
hamilton depression rating scale
and the percent recall from the hopkins
verbal learning trials
our antidepressant results are
summarized here
we changed the pulse width with approval
from our irb esmb
and namh program officers after a
planned interim analysis revealed a
trend of
inferior antidepressant response with
the 600 milliamp arm
with the ultra brief or 0.3 millisecond
pulse width
the rationale is based on the strength
duration curve which suggests that the
lower amplitudes may require more time
for neuronal activation
thus we reason that the increased pulse
width may improve the neuronal
activation potential
and anti-depressant efficacy of the 600
milliamp arm
this reality was not to materialize
unfortunately
the blue color is the 0.3 millisecond
pulse width and the green color is the
one millisecond pulse width
you can see in the 600 milliamp arm that
the
subjects really fail to respond to the
increase in pulse width
the within amplitude contrasts are
summarized here
the black dots are estimated marginal
means the blue bars are 95
confidence intervals and the red arrows
are for the comparison between the means
if the red comparison arrow from one
mean overlaps from another group the
results are not significant
based on the raw data noted above and
the within amplitude contrast
the red box highlights the 600 milliamp
arm which had initial improvement
but unfortunate plateau between the mid
and post dct assessments
the between amplitude contrasts are
summarized here
the second red box on your far right
highlights the post ect
hamilton depression rating scale
differences that demonstrate that the
600 milliamp arm
had inferior antidepressant outcomes
relative to both the 7 and 800 milliamp
arms
our primary cognitive measure which
again was the percent recall from the
hopkins verbal learning trials did not
demonstrate cognitive impairment
and this was consistent with other
measures of the hopkins verbal learning
trial
you can appreciate on the red lines
amongst the different
amplitudes how the results really did
not demonstrate any cognitive impairment
throughout the ect series with right and
lateral electroplacement
our secondary cognitive measures did
demonstrate amplitude mediated cognitive
impairment with the 800 milliamp arms
this was best demonstrated with phonemic
fluency which is illustrated here
these results were also similar with
the category fluency from the same
neuropsychological measure
the red box illustrates the cognitive
impairment notable within the 800
milliamp arm
they had a dramatic reduction in
phonemic fluency
performance between relative to the
pre-ect to mid-ect measure
and this impairment persisted to the end
of the ect treatment
in addition to clinical outcomes the
goal of this investigation
was to understand the relationships
between pulse amplitude
hippocampal electric field strength
hippocampal neuroplasticity and clinical
outcomes
the importance of eliminating
delineating these relationships is
illustrated with this slide
hippocampal electric field strength is
variable despite
constant current delivered outside the
skull
the red box illustrates the degree of
overlap with right hippocampal electric
field strength between our 6
7 and 800 milliamp arms
we assessed the relationship with
electric field neuroplasticity and
clinical outcomes
with the global ect mri collaboration
database with 190
subjects that completed ect with a right
in the lateral electroplacement
the results demonstrated a linear
relationship with the weaker left
hippocampal electric fields which is
contralateral to the right hemisphere
stimulus delivery
and potentially was related to a ceiling
effect on the right hippocampus
we did not find a relationship with
antidepressant outcomes which may be
related to a selection bias related to
the gimrick database
the selection bias is related to high
response rates for some of the sites
which could be up to 100 percent
and not reflective of routine clinical
ect care
we replicated this relationship between
electric field strength
and neuroplasticity with our brain
initiative project
we included the electric field from the
final post cct assessment
which may include big coral electrode
placement as time and treatment number
are critical variables when assessing
changes in neuroplasticity
in contrast to the gamma example which
included higher pulse amplitudes between
8 and 900 milliamps and a linear
relationship
with the electric field and
neuroplasticity in the left hippocampus
our sample included pulse amplitudes
that were much lower between 6 and 800
million
and demonstrated an equivalent linear
relationship between electric field
neuroplasticity and the right
hippocampus
electric field strength and
antidepressant outcomes did not
demonstrate a linear relationship
however extending our gameric analysis
the changes in right hippocampal
neuroplasticity
and antidepressant.com demonstrated a
very strong linear
relationship going back to
our cognitive outcomes the electric
field strength was related to cognitive
outcomes with the phonemic fluency
measure
the relationship between changes in
right hippocampal neuroplasticity
and cognitive outcomes depicted on your
right with a similar direction but less
robust
in summary our results suggest a
trade-off between antidepressant
outcomes where higher amplitudes may be
better
and cognitive outcomes where lower
amplitudes
are better further the imprecise
variable electric fields are associated
with
fixed amplitudes the increased electric
field strength associated with
hippocampal neuroplasticity
and the hippocampal neuroplasticity is
related to antidepressant outcomes
the sweet spot of fifth capital
neuroplasticity for optimal clinical
outcomes may be achieved with precise
ect dosing
for our next step we'll be using
amplitude titration to individualize
this precise
ect dose and reduce the risk of
cognitive impairment
while maintaining the antidepressant
outcomes
in conclusion i'd like to acknowledge
our grant support
with our project ect current amplitude
and medial temporal lobe
engagement as well as our collaborators
dr davenpoint at unm
dr eric gerhart at unm dr zdang at nimh
dr sean mcclintock at ut southwestern dr
mikalis arglin at zucker hillside
also our unm psychiatric research group
and our unm ect service and most
importantly gratitude to our ect
participants and now i'd like to
introduce our next speaker
dr ted stapler-white
thank you so today i'll be talking about
individual variation of association
network topography and youth
so i'm a psychiatrist and my lab
primarily studies the developing brain
the reason we do this is that the early
onset of most of our of most psychiatric
disorders and multiple sources of data
from animal studies epidemiologic
studies and translational studies in
humans
suggests that psychiatric disorders can
be conceptualized as disorders of brain
development
so the overall program of research we go
for
is to understand how the brain develops
normally and how abnormal brain
development is associated with different
forms of psychopathology
the goal here is to describe mental
illness in terms of these abnormal
trajectories of brain development so we
can intervene earlier and get better
outcomes for our patients
now clearly all this research has
important ethical considerations because
we're trying to develop
predictive biomarkers in children today
i'm going to be talking about recent
work that focuses
on large-scale functional brain networks
this has become
one of the dominant lenses for
understanding human brain organization
work using functional mri in humans has
shown that large-scale functional brain
networks at the macro scale are highly
reproducible
so here you can see work from thomas yo
and randy buckner
that shows that large-scale functional
brain networks are extremely
reproducible at the group level
so these uh functional mri can pull out
perceptual systems like the visual
system the motor system
as you can see they're in purple and in
blue however it can also pull out
higher order uh functional networks that
are responsible
for cognitive functions like executive
function which is critical in the
developing brain
however typically when we look at these
large-scale functional networks
as a field we use them in a fairly
one-size-fits-all sort of way
we and this assumes that the each
functional network is in the same
location
on the anatomic cortex of each
individual
however recent work in adults from
multiple independent laboratories has
shown that this assumption
is demonstrably false so work from
different laboratories using different
data sets and different methods
has shown that the spatial layout which
is called
the functional topography of these
large-scale functional networks vary
substantially
across individuals so where these
functional networks are located their
functional topography
varies between individuals furthermore
multiple convergent lines of evidence
has shown that
this variation itself is heterogeneous
and different parts of the cortex
have different amount of variability in
particular
higher order networks responsible for
executive function and complex cognition
are the most variable so you can see
here in yellow on the left
the again the front of parietal network
which is responsible for executive
function
this tends to be one of the most
variable networks and this has been seen
in multiple
independent adult data sets however
it wasn't really known how
this functional topography this
individual variation in
functional uh uh network layout
evolves in development and associates
with individual differences that we care
about
like executive function and one of the
reasons we care about executive function
and other higher order
uh cognitive capabilities is that is
that they're linked to all sorts of
outcomes that we care about for kids
so executive function is a broad
cognitive domain it includes things like
impulse control
cognitive control working memory and
it's linked to educational attainment
initiation of drug use violence etc and
so if we can understand
how functional topography develops in
kids is linked to these outcomes
it could be an important advance so this
is uh what my postdoc
daisukoi tackled in this project
and to and to address this question use
data from the philadelphia
neurodevelopmental cohort the
philadelphia neurodevelopmental cohort
or pnc
this is the study not the bank it uh
spans
ages 8 to 22. it includes an even mix of
males and females
and even mix of caucasians and
african-americans it was led by
penn by raquel gur and to delineate
individual
individualized functional networks we
used a recently developed machine
learning technique called non-negative
matrix factorization
with spatial regularization this was
developed by our collaborators
um hongming lee and yang fond and
they've in a previous work they've
shown that using resting state data from
the human
uh connectome project they can pull out
individual specific networks
that align extremely well with
individual patterns of task fmri
activation
so here in a sample of nearly 700
uh kids from the philadelphia
neurodevelopmental cohort
we use this non-negative matrix
factorization to define individualized
networks
and the first step of this is to take
the 27 minutes of very high quality fmri
data we have
and build a group atlas and the reason
for this is to ensure that the networks
are
present in all individuals and have
correspondence across individuals so we
can analyze the data
and the group atlas that we pull out is
very similar to other group atlases that
have been published in the literature
however the key thing the next step
is that then that group atlas is
tailored to each individual's functional
neural anatomy
and when you look at individual
participant data you can see that there
actually is a tremendous amount of
variation in dysfunctional topography
so here on the left we see the uh on
this slide we see
the group atlas and what's important
know is that this non-negative matrix
factorization technique
produces a soft parcelation so each
vertex gets a loading for each network
this can be discretized for display but
really it actually has more power as a
soft
personalization and if you look at how
these networks are distributed
individuals
you can see these higher order networks
responsible for executive function
like the front of parietal network and
the ventral attention network on that
bottom row
that there's a tremendous amount of
spatial variability how they're laid out
in individuals
now we can look at this statistically
across the entire sample of nearly 700
kids
and we can see that just as in studies
of adults the network variability is
maximal in association cortex
so you can see here on the left-hand
panel that uh
the variability is maximum in front of
parietal cortex
and other higher order association
cortex and you can quantify this network
by network across the 17 networks that
we defined
on the right hand panel and again the
front of parietal network is the most
variable
but also other association networks are
much more variable than low order
networks like the visual system or the
motor system on the left hand of that
violin plot
so we've basically replicated uh
findings for an adult so far and shown
that there's a lot of variability in the
functional topography and the
variability is maximal in higher order
association cortex
especially that's the the parts of the
networks that are responsible for
executive function so next though what
we want to understand
is how this functional topography
related to things we cared about like
executive function
and changed with age
so one first crack of the data we took
was to summarize this very complex data
in a very simple way so we derived a
summary measure what we call the total
network representation
the total network representation is
literally the sum of the weights
of each functional network over the
entire cortex
it basically summarizes how much real
estate
each individualized network takes up on
a given person's cortex
now i want to one important point is
this is all done in normalized space
so we're not aliasing in individual
differences
and cortical surface area so this
basically says okay this total network
representation says
how much a given network is uh taking up
on
the cortex of a given individual and
what we found
was that this total network
representation doesn't change
much over the age range that we study
between 8 and 22. it's not like these
networks
are expanding or contracting
dramatically over the adolescent period
however we did find that total network
net total network representation
was associated with executive function
while controlling for h
so in fact what we found is that the
networks that were responsible for
executive function
like here on the left-hand panel the two
frontal two of the frontal parietal
networks
individuals who have more total network
representation of those executive
networks
perform better on executive tasks
so if they have more real estate devoted
to the executive networks they're
performing better at executive function
so this is a very very simple measure as
i said next we wanted to look at the
overall
complex multivariate pattern of
functional topography
and we found looking at the overall high
dimensional data
that we could predict executive function
with a reasonable degree of accuracy and
completely unseen data
to do this we use split half ridge
regression with nested parameter tuning
and what we found is that we can predict
executive function in the second half of
the data the model hadn't seen
and vice versa so we see prediction
correlations of 0.46 complete out of
sample testing
this is well beyond the precision of a
permutation testing procedure
and we were actually pretty pleased with
this this is a higher level prediction
we often see from functional mri
and shows that this functional this
pattern of functional topography
has important implications for behavior
however the next step we wanted to see
whether this whether again
this pattern of functional topography
was related to age and previously
in the when we were looking at the total
network representation we saw no
relationship
and so somewhat to our surprise
we saw that actually we could predict an
individual child's age with an even
higher degree of accuracy than we could
predict their executive function
again in complete out-of-sample testing
here we could predict an individual's
uh child's age within a two-year margin
of error
in a correlation of around 0.66 in in
out-of-sample testing
so that was somewhat surprising to us
because we know we know from the total
network representation these networks
aren't
aren't expanding or contracting much
over development so what could be
driving this effect so we took
so as i should did a number of analyses
try to investigate this
and what he found was that the features
that were driving the model
to be able to decode an unseen
individual's age
were present in association cortex and
the same association cortex in fact
that is most variable across individuals
so the association cortex topography
that varies the most among kids
also is what allows us to predict their
age
we would dug a little further and i
think that all the details are in the
paper and
what seems to be going on here is that
association network
topography at the edges of the network
is being refined over development
even though the gross amount of area
that they're taking up isn't expanding
or contracting
so as a final step
we want to understand how this network
variability which is related to age and
predicts executive function is
constrained by fundamental properties of
brain organization
so here what we did is we tried to
understand the relationship between
network variability
and fundamental properties like
evolutionary expansion
cortical myelin content and cerebral
blood flow
and to do this we used an extremely
conservative spatial permutation
testing procedure developed by iron
alexander block and we
plotted the network variability here on
the y axis of each of these plots
versus evolutionary expansion versus
cortical myelin content and versus
means cerebral blood flow what you can
see is that
these highly variable networks also
are have a high level of evolutionary
expansion have a low
cortical myelin content and elevated
cerebral blood flow
so i'm going to summarize these results
and try to put them together for you so
first we found that in adults functional
network topography
is highest in association networks and
youth
the spatial layout of these functional
networks varies a lot across individuals
just like we've seen adults
and the mo these networks tend to be
most variable in higher order
association cortex we look across the hp
and studied we found that kids who were
better at executive functioning
had the greater total network
representation of the
networks that are devoted executive
function like the front of parietal
network
furthermore we found that this
complex uh functional topography of the
species of association networks allowed
us to predict the age of individuals
and the executive performance of
individuals in unseen data
using ridge regression in unseen data
finally the cortex that allowed us to
breed
to predict age and executive function
that is also the most
variable in individuals we found is
though
is the same cortex that is that is
expanded through evolution
is lightly myelinated and receives
disproportionate through blood flow
if you put all this together the results
are remarkably consistent with
a model developed by fenugreene and
randy buckner
whereby in evolution association
networks become untethered
from rigid hardwired developmental
programming and
the thought is that this loss of
tethering and lack of hard wiring allows
for greater adaptability in development
but also comes at higher metabolic costs
and also potential
vulnerability to neuropsychiatric
syndromes
so this work has motivated a lot of
stuff we're working on now
as well as things we're planning this
includes relating it directly
to psychopathology going from cognitive
function to
clinical uh symptoms and so currently
she was working on a paper where
he uses multiview machine learning
techniques to link this
diversity of functional topography to
different measures of psychopathology in
a data-driven way
we're currently working with mike millam
uh in the healthy brain
network data to try to replicate and
generalize these results and we're
planning
to look at how these individual specific
functional networks
evolve on a person-specific basis over
time
using data from the adolescent brain and
cognitive development project in
collaboration with damian fair
finally and perhaps most excitingly in
work funded by the brain initiative
our collaborators desmond oaths and
young fan are using these individual
specific networks to target tms
so i want to end there by thanking the
huge team that is required for this sort
of work in particular as i shukui
the postdoc who did literally all of the
work for this project i want to thank
raquel gur the overall
the overall pi of the pnc and our
collaboration our collaborators in
radiology and bioengineering young thon
and hong wing lee
who developed the non-negative matrix
factorization technique
lastly i want to thank our funding
sources in particular the brain
initiative
and nimh who's made all this research
possible as well as our study
participants and their families
thank you
thank you all so much for those
wonderful talks and i want to extend a
thank you also to the audience for your
patience with us as we work through some
of these technical challenges today
we're going to open it now for some live
question and
answers i'm going to start with chris
so chris for your ect amplitude dosing
you looked at sort of the trade-off
between clinical outcomes and um
and side effects and i'm wondering if
you can talk a little bit about
what you think might be a specific
amplitude for optimal clinical outcomes
based on the work that you've done and
the results that you've seen so far
sure thank you uh looking at the
trade-off
between the six seven and 800 milliamp
arms
when we did an older patient population
between 50 and 80 years of age
it looks like 700 represents a cut off
where the inflection point about
non-response shifts
to increased ect response
this was also consistent with the
cognitive side effects looking at
phonemic as well as category fluency
where the 700 milliamp does seem to have
less
cognitive impairment however there is
tremendous variability
some of the 700 milliamp subjects had an
e field specifically in the hippocampus
that mirrored the 600 milliamp arms so
prior to recommending a different
amplitude is retaining clinical care i
think we need to take a step back
and really try and develop a method for
improving the precision of ect dosing
basically what happens outside the skull
is constant but inside the skull is
highly variable and we really want to
flip that maybe have
individualized amplitudes to achieve the
same
endpoint about what's happening inside
the skull
methods to do that would be e field form
bct which would have
limited translational impact we would
really like to employ some of the work
of dr listenbee
with amplitude titration and come up
with a multiplier to where we can do
amplitude titration to standardize the
dose and then
incorporate a neuroplasticity multiplier
thank you chris the next question is for
helen mayberg do you think
that there is a change in receptability
to rehabilitation following the dbs
treatment and have any of the patients
seen changes
in their psychiatric treatment efficacy
pre or post
dbs um thank you
brooks that's an interesting question
and kind of
resonates with what we observe these
people by definition
have failed ect psychotherapy
and at least four medications and it's
remarkable
the absence almost of side effects to
really extreme doses of medications that
they're on
you know prior to entering the study
they can
attempt to do psychotherapy but it's
just ineffective
as they're not demented there's a
disconnect
between the thought and the training and
actually have it
hold and what we notice is that
even from the beginning they have
capacity
to take on more activities so
interventions
like behavioral activation can be
really the first course because they
really don't yet seem to have the
machinery
to engage in the kind of rehabilitation
strategies
that the full-blown cognition behavioral
therapy requires
but actually after six eight weeks
it seems to shift and we're really
interested to know
if our changes in the brain going from a
low beta to a high data might reflect
this
transition so yes they become more
responsive even years out they don't
tend to relapse
and when there's minor fluctuations one
can make
dose adjustments in their medication
actually
we never change the dose of the dbs over
years once we get an effective
dose so the answer is yes
thank you helen our next question is
coming in
for kareem so kareem since you are
studying uh patients with epilepsy do
you make or see
any distinction between the
physiological
and pathological ripples that you may
actually be recording from the
intracranial eeg
so thank you for the question i think
it's a very good question um
as you noted we are recording uh from
patients who do have epilepsy and so in
those patients we do
often see uh pathological activity both
intrical discharges as well as
pathological ripples people have studied
these ripples
uh these pathological ripples and there
has been some suggestions literature
that they actually
are detrimental rather than beneficial
for cognition
uh we in our work generally when we are
thinking about normal memory retrieval
we try as best as possible to remove
pathological
events from our data analysis so we try
to exclude electrodes that are involved
in badlas productivity
as well as individual trials that
exhibit what we find
is in the ripples that we capture we see
these sequences of spiking activity that
are actually
relevant for memory retrieval we
hypothesize but we haven't actually
shown this yet but we plan to do this we
hypothesize that if we were to look at
the pathological ripples
what we expect to see are sequences of
psychiatry that are actually not
uh organized in a consistent manner or
that may not be organized in a way that
is beneficial for memory
again we haven't really done this but
that would be sort of our working
hypothesis at this point
thanks green the next question is for
ted
do individual differences in functional
topography relate in any way to
underlying anatomical or structural
differences
across individuals or are they distinct
yeah that's an excellent question i
think uh one thing to
note at the beginning is there is a lot
of anatomic variability in the same
places that there's
differences in functional topography
however the tools that we've used for a
while
are much better at handling them so
modern image
registration techniques with deformable
registrations and service-based
registrations
can line up the structural brains quite
well and uh
so techniques have accounted for that
and we've been able to study that in the
past
and previously we've just ignored the
functional variability and assumed that
by lining up brain structure we're also
lining up
brain function and so this is a
different axis of variability the
structural variability that has been
previously ignored
and by not accounting for this we're
basically aliasing in the spatial
distribution
of our variability functional networks
to any measurement of connectivity
so i think they're both important
sources of variability uh just one
hadn't been well studied in the past
great and our last question for
um jen jen do you do the transient
and tonic components represent motor
intent
in the data that you are collecting or
do you think that they could be related
to the brain processing of sensory
events
yeah thanks that's a really interesting
question you know and i'm not sure that
we can really ever completely separate
motor intent from sensory feedback
because those are so tightly linked
together
i think the evidence that we have
suggest that these are primarily
representing
motor intent and i can tell you a few
reasons why one is
we are able to record from some areas in
somatosensory cortex and while we do see
that there is a
transient and tonic response it tends to
be more muted than what we're measuring
in motor cortex at least for this
particular task
but if you remember that you know we're
working with people with spinal cord
injury who are really
imagining and attempting to perform
these movements so they're not getting
any actual
sensory feedback during this task and so
what we're measuring here is really
you know kind of that forward model
command
to the to the limb i think um you know
it's hard to say because these
participants do have traumatic spinal
cord injury and in the past have
actually grasped with their own hands
and so you know it may be that they have
this
efferent communication or afferent
communication going back and forth
between some other
metasensory and motor cortex that has
driven these memories but right now
we're seeing these responses in the
absence of any actual
sensory feedback
thank you jen um the next question i
have is for helen
did you find anything in your
data so far that you did not expect
well i think we had i mean you always
find things in your data you don't
expect
but i think that what has
been helpful for us is to actually let
the data tell us what we should see
rather than actually thinking we knew
what we were going to see
and this switch between
a signal that happened early actually
transitioned and actually morphed into
a different kind of signal late and the
appreciation
that the recovery wasn't linear neither
at
the clinical level but neither at the
brain level
and i think it really gives us pause out
about how to think about what these
devices do do they reset the brain and
the rest is
all rehab are we looking at
acute changes and then plasticity
changes i think we have to have
different models
and that's really something we have to
pay more attention to now
great question is for
kareem again um which micro
micro electrodes excuse me array did you
use
and where do you think these units are
located within the brain
so the microelectrode array that we used
was the
uh what's locally known as the utah
microscope it's an array of 96
microelectrodes arranged in a four by
four millimeter grid
so each microelectrode is based from its
neighbor by approximately 400 microns
uh we place these electrodes in the vast
majority of cases
in the middle temporal gyrus of the
anterior temporal lobe so the lateral
temporal cortex
just because that's the area that we
have access to when we're performing our
initial surgery for placement of the
clinical contacts
again largely we are placing these
microelectrodes in this region because
this is an area that we anticipate that
we are going to resect and so as best
as possible we try to put these arrays
in areas of the brain that we think is
going to be removed so it doesn't have
any long-term consequences
uh the electrodes themselves each extend
approximately a millimeter
into the cortex so we don't know for
sure exactly which
layer they are reporting from but we
think that it's approximately layer
three or layer four neurons in that part
of the lateral temporal cortex
thanks cream um the next question i have
here
is for gen uh with your decoding
approach would someone be able to change
the amount of force
that they are applying to an object
thanks for the question so yeah we've
actually looked at this a little bit
because the way that the task
is designed that i presented was the
hand is starts open
at least they visually see that and then
it closes and starts to apply the force
and we initially measured that
transient response during that closing
phase so we weren't sure
if that was related to you the kinematic
movement of the hand
but actually even during an isometric
grasp when you're holding on to the
object
if the user wants to increase or
decrease that force we see that they
enter back into that same
transient dimension and so we can use a
single decoder
to either apply that initial force or
change it
as you as you go along and so it's we're
not really switching back and forth but
we're looking at the probability
of whether you're in that transient
state or not and that tends to be high
again if you want to change your force
great thank you jen and we are going to
wrap up the
question and answers with um that last
answer from jen and again i want to
thank all of our speakers we really
appreciate
you uh taking the time to work through
the pre-recording and joining us today
for the live question to answer
it's wonderful um that we can all do
this virtually
in this very sort of different time that
we're in right now
and thank you to the audience for your
participation and your attention
and i hope everyone stays well and
enjoyed the symposium thank you
you